humans have been moving plants around
the world for many centuries recent
research has indicated that about 3% of
the world's vascular flora have become
established and naturalized in new areas
outside their their native range largely
moved around by by people what we're
realizing though now is that some of
these plants can become invasive this is
a little calop Tran thiis Cordillera
piccola here is one we're doing a quite
a lot of work on and one of my favorites
acacia and a guard Ensis originally
thought only from the island of Anegada
and I found it on fallen Jerusalem a
couple of years ago so Q had been
running a UK overseas territories
program for more than 15 years providing
botanical support for the territories
but particularly we have the collection
from the British Virgin Islands under
threat from invasive species being
Islands there's a really interesting
flora there and Islands typically have a
wide range of paths unique to those
islands and so the British Virgin
Islands is no different Metis telma Anna
Garden Sea is known from only one Island
the island of Anegada and it occupies an
area probably less than 27 square
kilometers and that's its global
population and it's that community
that's being invaded now by a range of
non-native species so when it comes to
the invasive species we wouldn't keep
those in the living collections but
we've got them here as herbarium
specimens and there's very little
difference between the invasives and the
endemics you wouldn't know from looking
at the herbarium specimens that hey I'm
an invasive plant surprising how few
people in many places are aware of the
challenge and the threats posed by
invasive species
so here we are at Lakehurst place a part
of two gardens in the high Weald of
Sussex and what we're doing here is
controlling rhododendron that that
infamous feast but that's ravaging
native woodlands and my colleague James
here does all of the hard work is
actively removing it using a tried and
tested technique a chainsaw we cut it
down and then we use herbicide to kill
the plant well these are sand stones and
so at wakers place and in the high Weald
we have this wonderful geology of sand
rock and this sand rock provides a
wonderful habitat for mosses for lichens
for liverwort sand for ferns there's
some like getting through here so you
can see some life but as we move further
into the rhododendron thicket you'll see
it becomes very very dark and these
rocks are almost devoid of any lower
plants growing on them whatsoever in
contrast here we are and looking at a
rock that's really verdun full of life
this is Tunbridge filmy fern a very very
rare plant that only grows at a few
locations in West Sussex so this area
that we're in has never seen those dense
canopies of rhododendron and that's why
this rock is really thriving with these
lower plants and so removing
rhododendron from other parts of the
estate is absolutely essential
well here at Kew we've got about 30,000
species in our living collections a
product of many centuries of plant
collections and they're from all over
the world and some of them have
naturalized on our site but they're not
a problem because they're not ones that
are becoming invasive and any that do we
now are aware of problems of potential
invasion so we do carry out a risk
assessment on all new acquisitions and
anything that looks like
it might be invasive will not display so
it's now really beginning to take the
central stage in conservation biology
that it really needs to before it's too
late and we we hand on and invasive
dominated planet quite different to the
the diverse native of dominated one that
we inherited from our forebearers